one of the things that I did I had I was
talking to a gentleman a couple I'm
going I'm going to let the debate
breathe but it's his turn let's take
let's take turns so I was talking to a
fella who had made the move from
California uh to Florida and he was
telling me that Florida is much better
governed uh safer better budget uh lower
taxes all this stuff and he's really
happy with the quality of life and then
he paused and he said and oh by the way
I'm Gavin nome's father-in-law so we do
count Gavin's in-laws as some of the
people have fled California um and come
to the State of Florida nice look Ronda
santis you might say he's not the
slickest he's not the prettiest he
doesn't smile the best but that guy
prepares he prepared for that debate and
Nome is a super smart politician too
Nome saw that attack coming a mile away
that's why he tried to interrupt him
that's why he tried to derail him but
Des santis wouldn't get derailed